tired of angry birds and words with
friends on your iPhone if you're hungry
for something a bit more gritty rockstar
has just the game to fill you up an
enhanced version of grand theft auto
liberty City Stories is available on the
App Store as of today December 17th this
is going to put us you want me on the
map big time for seven bucks you can
download the 10 year old PSP classic on
compatible iOS devices an android
version is on the way to but no date has
been announced new features included an
enhanced draw distance rebalanced
controls for touch-based play and
glorious 60 frames-per-second gameplay
and yes you can turn your itunes
playlists into a custom radio station
the definitive version of this Grand
Theft Auto classic can now go wherever
your phone goes just don't answer it if
Roman calls about going bowling again
but you can feel free to use it to
follow me on twitter at chain-gun Pope
and of course check out all the Grand
Theft Auto news on gamespot com